so Ron DeSantis has revoked the liquor
license of the Hyatt Regency in Miami
for hosting a drag show in which
children were present this is an adult
performance adult entertainment
and kids were there and they were warned
if they let kids in they would lose
their liquor license now I see a lot of
people celebrating this and it is big
news but my attitude is kind of like
that's it so what you're saying the next
time they do it they just won't be drunk
okay well at least it's something but
I'm I'm of the mind that people who
break the law because they actually
cited statute that was in violent they
were in violation of I think if you
break the law you should be arrested and
charged I'm not saying that a person who
jaywalk should be a resident charge and
sent prison for a million years you
might get a citation depending on the
scale of the crime but we're talking
about people who willfully violated the
law were warned they were violating the
law and then decided to have an adult
performance for children
the exhibits presented by Rhonda Santos
are really messed up simply put really
messed up like showing
actual let's just call it abuse of a
child in this document so we'll talk
about that we're originally going to
lead with the Russian jet slamming into
a drone and the fear that this will lead
to some kind of escalation because the
bud Administration is basically saying
oh this is an act of aggression by the
Russians our drone was operating in
international territory and they hit it
blah blah yeah it's bad and there may be
an overreaction but probably just in
terms of funding and providing more
weapons which we've already seen I'm not
sure where that's exactly going to go
and whether or not it's the biggest deal
in the world but we'll talk about that
plus we've got uh deep concerns about
the financial crisis Moody's is
downgrading uh the U.S due to dramatic
instability and as we already saw the
other day with the collapse of svb first
it was silvergate then svb then
signature there are concerns that uh
it's just completely unstable the market
today a bunch of banks rebounded so much
so that their uh trading on their stocks
was also halted which is just another
sign of absolute volatility so we'll see
we'll see I don't know for sure but
we'll talk about this before we get
started head over to timcast.com click
that join us button become a member to
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to exclusive
uncensored members only shows Monday
through Thursday we have those Live
recorded live around 10 10 pm every day
day and then they go up and there's a
big archive you can watch all of the
uncensored members on these shows not so
family friendly if you like the work we
do we need your support as members
because that's how this operation is
funded as you all know BuzzFeed is
particularly panicked because not only
was there money in svb but they've
reported their ad revenue is going to
drop by like 30 40 percent that's true
for everybody so if you really like what
we do become a member to support our
work but don't forget to also smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about this and so
much more is Jim Hansen Hey Brother good
to be with you absolutely who are you
what do you do I run a company called
worldstrat that does information
operations to push the envelope on the
narratives that I like
right on simply put all right I also got
a book oh a book huh your favorite topic
get based well all right looking cool
we'll we'll do our best try you already
do it brother all right we got Phil
Labonte hanging out how you doing
philibonti lead singer for All That
Remains anti-communist kante
revolutionary
I'm Hannah Claire brimlaw I'm a writer
for timcast.com
uh and I am a surge.com ready to do it
let's jump into this first story I love
this one I chose the new Republic as our
principal source for this story because
it's funny and got a picture of Rhonda
Sanders right here and then it says Ron
DeSantis is now attacking the Hyatt
Regency because it hosted a drag show
the Florida governor has been waging a
war on drag and on lgbtq people in his
state they say Florida Governor Ryan
Sanders moved Tuesday to strip the
height Regency of its liquor license for
allegedly allowing miners to attend a
Christmas time drag show I love how they
how they do that allegedly there's
pictures of children there there's video
of a drag queen
with fake breasts shoving them into the
face of a child
there's there's children at this show
allegedly
and they say he's cracking down an lgbtq
rights it's the crazy thing is these
people by any stretch of the imagination
must be pedophiles because there's no
reason why they would lie about what
descent is actually did unless they were
pedophiles so is Rhonda Sanders going
after lgbtq people no he explicitly said
if you have minors at an adult
entertainment show you will lose your
liquor license and even threaten them
with a rest I'm gonna go one step
further and say right now Ron DeSantis
arrest these people I would like to see
State Police go to the Hyatt Regency
walk up to the manager confirm were you
the manager on the night of December I
think it was 27th or something 2022
during the performance of the drag show
in which children were present yes place
your hands behind your back you are
under arrest and we're going to have you
register as a sex offender because you
facilitated the whole thing then find
the employees who helped facilitate this
and they get charges as well for aiding
and abetting a a sex show in which
children were present you doing parents
too what about the performance it's it's
oh absolutely absolutely the thing is
he's targeting the height Regency so I'm
speaking in the context of the Hyatt
Regency
there's an interesting question about
the performers they're not the ones who
let in the children but
we'll see we'll see you see a child in
front of you you go walk up on them and
create a sex act exactly I think they're
culpable absolutely so those people but
I'm not sure they're residents of the
state they may have been passing through
in which case good luck getting federal
charges but if they ever step foot back
in there should be an arrest here's what
really bothers me about this story is
that there's photos of this I don't I
don't want to show all the photos I
think YouTube might get us in trouble if
I show you like right here down at the
bottom of the screen uh why can't I see
it on the
that's weird well I guess the mouse
doesn't appear normally it does well on
the bottom of the screen there's a
picture of a drag queen shoving their
chest into a child's face and uh we just
you know try and move away from that one
because I don't think we can actually
show that
what bothers me is that Rhonda Santos
only is taking away their liquor license
so the response is if you host a sex
show where you invite children we'll
take away your ability to sell beer
don't you think that he's kind of
baiting them I think okay you take their
liquor license you dare them to do it
again and the second time you send the
SWAT team you frog March them out in
Chains and you alert the media why the
second time because the government never
wants to jump in the first time with
everything they never throw everything
at it the first time I remember a story
about a guy who put grow lights in an
empty house and then a bunch of I was a
DEA agents stormed into the building
only to find nothing was in it he was
live streaming a sting operation and his
point was that they were going to come
in with no war into a house that did
nothing wrong yet right now we're
supposed to cheer for Rhonda santis
and he's like I took away their liquor
license now when they have sex shows for
children they'll have to be sober am I
supposed to be happy about that I'll
tell you I guess a little bit I'll take
baby steps rather than no steps we've
done nothing up to this point yeah we
haven't even stopped him from doing
anything so at least this take away
their revenue stream you're costing them
money right and and if it's the if the
threat is the next time they will get
cuffed and stuffed I'd like to see it
someone's this is the over this is the
Overton window being shifted first they
do literal nothing then people complain
and they say we'll take away their
liquor license they can still operate
they can still sell uh um you know shows
at their Event Center they can still
have people come into the uh you know
the the restaurant order food you can
still rent rooms at the Hyatt no worries
okay I'm shouting out right now to my
friends in Miami who know the DeSantis
crew let's send in a SWAT team why why
should the Hyatt Regency be concerned
about their liquor license when their
principal business is selling hotel
rooms but if they operate a food and
beverage business liquor tends to be one
of those that's the high margin that's
margin so I mean I think what's
happening is they're trying to scare the
Hyatt Regency into not accepting a
contract from this group anymore and
that'll just send them to another venue
which then I guess will continue to
chase about it doesn't seem like the
most effective strategy to stopping them
you guys know that we've been to
Congress now a couple times they have a
Subway in the uh which building were we
in I don't know there's a Subway imagine
if a member of Congress did something
illegal so they went and said we're not
going to let that Subway operate anymore
and I'll show these corrupt members of
Congress they're going to be like okay
I'll go across the street to get Subway
so if you're staying at the Hyatt
Regency you just get drunk across the
street you rent your room their
principal business is completely
unaffected I gotta say look I I get it
some action is good to try and stop the
Overton window shift that's allowing
this this grooming that's happening but
all they're really doing it seems to me
is throwing red meat at people who are
upset about this and then saying cheer
for the nothing that I have done I have
done nothing at all to stop this quite
nothing I have hurt the bottom line of
one height location by seven percent if
that I'm willing to bet alcohol
comprises a fraction of a percentage of
their revenue they don't care the right
does nothing yeah there you go period
they never do they they do it's all for
show they don't they're just as you know
just as interested in virtue signaling
as anyone else
um if this is considered action
then the left has nothing to fear from
the right agreed
or about Murray and Peter who presented
the drag queen Christmas like I I want
to know what the production company is
doing because they're probably operating
I mean typically hotels bid for
contracts and then whichever one works
out a deal with the organization that
wants to book the space you know moves
forward with contracts so who else
considered who else tried to get this
drag queen Story show if we can't have
it at the Hyatt where is it going now I
think that's what bothers me the most
like yes it's not enough of an action
from DeSantis but partially because it
keeps the head on the snake we're not
really stopping it from Just migrating
somewhere else across town let's get
citizens given tips for every drag show
coming up and dare DeSantis not to react
to the next one you know I don't care if
adults want to have a drag show if they
want to do burlesque if they want to do
Go-Go dancing if they want scantily clad
men and women standing you know swinging
around in Poles that's fine just no kids
if the right wants to do something about
it they should be putting the performers
that are that are performing for
children in jail Rhonda Santos if you
really believed these people if you
really thought this was true would be
he'd have the D.A issue arrest warrants
for these individuals and upon their
return to the state for any reason they
would immediately be arrested well I'm
sure a bunch of them are local it's not
it was a touring thing but I'm sure they
invite local talent in like that's
pretty normal I'm confident that shows I
think to do something this is a 37 State
touring show I'm not sure it was a local
thing I think it was a touring are there
any other states that have laws has
anybody else passed the law Texas Texas
no no Texas a a drag show where they
were presenting sex in front of children
and the police said I refuse to get
involved
so it's like look man I understand that
um we're looking for Hope where we can
find it and a lot of people they don't
want to be black pilled but if I'm
supposed to cheer for Ron DeSantis for
having done the bare minimum literally
the least he could possibly do about
this
I guess it's better than the rest of the
states that do literal nothing like Greg
Abbott but uh yeah I'm just
unenthused
not optimistic about where this is all
going well shaming helps so I'll start
public shaming on it tomorrow that's
fair point I would love to see I mean
the video of a drag queen being hauled
out of a bar in handcuffs would go a
long way towards throwing a little
gasoline I honestly think the manager of
the establishment that facilitated a sex
show for children should be brought out
wearing their nice little button-up
shirt and tie with their pens in their
pocket being like I don't understand why
I'm being arrested I operate an
establishment and then as they're being
brought out the police can say he
operated a sex show for children and
they'll go whoa jail and make sure that
the inmates that he shares that he
shares uh jail with make sure they know
because I don't care about any of that
weird stuff man just
have him register as a sex offender and
that's see that's a huge threat right
there because they're not doing anything
no they did but that's a great one
that's a great tool right there if you
operate a sex show because it used to be
10 years ago 15 years ago a drag show
was dudes in ball gowns singing Abba yes
right right you know now they're wearing
g-strings and shoving their groins
simulating birth and abortion that's
just so different that's that's a
completely different thing it's not
burlesque it's not a drag show it's a
perverted section
they point out in the complaint that the
one of the videos played actually shows
genitals it actually shows the nudity
and things like that which is crime so
let's I'm with you dude I think the
let the shaming begin there we all have
voices right okay there's two things
that I want to say first of all I agree
that that stigma is not used enough
nowadays like it it's like so social
shaming is used for for basically for
the wrong things essentially and there
should be more shaming from people on
the right which speaks to Tim's point
and and uh Matt Walsh's point about you
know being more aggressive I think is
probably a better way to describe it but
they they were saying be more mean but
shaming is good and it's it's what you
should use in place of legislation so
I'm not a big fan of of having like I'm
not a big fan of SWAT teams and stuff
like that generally so I think that it's
better to have Society shame people and
and try to discourage uh Behavior you
know
um so I think that that's the spot let's
go if you're at a drag show take the
license plates fill them out drop them
then you're dropping names docs them
online no no no you can't well you can't
say that please but but none of that
weird stazi Soviet stuff we have laws on
the books they cited the laws on the
books and they're doing nothing about it
I don't want to I like I I don't I don't
care for this right on your neighbor's
stuff we shouldn't have to we should
have a society that enforces its own
laws when those laws exist instead I get
it you know we got a super chat here
Rocky says the point of point of liquor
license is to show the smaller
establishments that it's serious but let
me pull up this next story there you go
from the post to millennial woke New
York attorney general Democrat lawmakers
to host drag queen's story event for
families the event is set to feature
drag performers reading to children so
now you have in New York state sponsored
Dragon shows for kids I can't get past
the why do you demand that drag
performers read to Children
then you know the answer I do yeah but
the thing is the average person should
at least be asking the question as
opposed to saying well this is what I'm
supposed to be doing so all the Cairns
just decide to show up so that way they
can get the the Kudos at the at the PTA
in their in their academic paper they
wrote the goal is to get glitter in the
carpet that can never be removed quite
literally outlining in their paper trans
pedagogy how to groom children that's
what's the instructions once you do that
you you open the door to nothing being
better or worse than anything else so
being trans being non-binary be being a
forest elf whatever you think you are is
equally good to being a CIS head person
who who has a family and makes babies
and that destroys the ability for the
culture to say anything is better than
anything else it's all equally fine
people people are saying look I don't
want to act like
Rhonda said is pulling a liquor license
from the Hyatt is literal nothing it's
the bare minimum I'll take it I'm not
I'm not mad that he did it okay I'm
happy something is happening but you
have in Florida them saying you're a
large establishment and we're going to
take away your liquor license even
though your principal business is
selling hotel rooms and doing
large-scale events I suppose losing your
liquor license for large-scale events
can be painful meanwhile on the other
side New York is like we're going to
State sponsor all this stuff if they're
in while California is doing the same
thing so if you think this is winning
the culture War you will lose we will
lose and in 10 years you'll be wondering
why your state of Florida is the capital
of child drag shows
well but isn't it also going to drive
people to self-separate into tribes
again okay if New York is where the
state sponsors drag queen Story Hour in
Florida you at least are starting to
stigmatize it and starting to pre-create
consequences for people who perpetrate
it then guess what more people are going
to leave more taxpayers more productive
people are going to leave New York which
is good here's the thing we are a nation
of weak men we have for too long have
we've gone from the classical liberal
sense of Live and Let Live into the do
whatever you want for whatever reason
leave me alone there's a big difference
between Live and Let Live and do
whatever you want but leave me alone we
used to have shared moral foundations
and so our country was like look
go to your house do your thing but then
if they did things that were considered
bad or destructive the bigger picture we
would still be like either shun or
criminal charges depending on the
severity of the things they were doing
even so so the point is like drug use
and things like that but now we've gone
so far to the anyone can do anything
they want this the country is ripping in
half where you've got adult men putting
on sex shows let me hear Let pull this
up pull it up let me just show you the
picture there there there's there's a
drag queen with fake breasts and
children were present there's videos of
it
faith and and doing weird sex things at
this show so New York's going to allow
it and what's going to happen is the men
in New York are going to say I don't
care you can do whatever you want and I
think it's even worse you said I want to
do whatever I want leave me alone it's
not leave me alone it's celebrate my
freakishness you know now you have to
actually have the kids because he's got
the kids participating in Pride parades
and carrying flags and doing all that so
they're telling them it's not just there
if you want to teach kids what is good
what do you celebrate we celebrate pride
month you know so you've got an entire
month where you're telling them these
people who are abnormal I'm not saying
they're bad people but they're outside
the norm of society and they're doing
things that may or may not be healthy
and you're telling kids that's something
to celebrate you know what's funny is
that uh the rainbow is the symbol of
God's covenant to to man that he will
never flood the Earth again and they
decide to I want it right back I know
that's but it's also funny that they
have pride celebrations which of course
is one of the seven deadly sins
I wonder I wonder if a lot of it is
intended to attack religion and
Christianity because like you said James
Lindsay is great at pointing out that
it's Praxis all right these these are
things they're doing purposely because
they're attacking the things that are
cohesive and hold a society together and
they're purposely targeting the things
like a nuclear family and the the CIS
hat normality as something to be
destroyed and it's working satisfied
people do not Revolt you don't get a
revolution when you have a society full
of people that are happy drag Story Hour
the nonprofit that's co-sponsoring the
New York AG Story Hour in their mission
statement they have this line that says
uh we capture the imagination and play
of gender fluidity in childhood and give
kids glamorous positive and unabashedly
queer role models for the nonprofit like
they know why they are preaching to
children and they're watching co-opting
childhood if we see as innocent say oh
well actually children are gender fluid
that's that's in their basic bio they
assume that all children are gender
fluid which is weird that's not what I
mean it's abnormal and they're they get
on TV they get nothing but Dad is an
idiot right mom should run things and
the gay couple is cooler yeah you know
so all all of the the things are now
designed to push you towards one thing
and and it's working you know and the
fact that we're at least having this
conversation the fact that there's at
least a liquor license in Jeopardy and
hopefully someone will be in handcuffs
is a step in the right direction but it
is a baby step and we need much bigger
steps how how is it that we've gone from
what do you think would have happened 40
years ago
if something like this was done if they
had an event like this with Children
what do you think the governments would
have done I don't think the governments
would have been involved because we
still had culture then we still had a
culture where parents would have been
responsible and they would have shown up
and whoever was doing that would have
had a very sad day you know you think
people in the community would show up
and they would be a riot yeah so baby
steps you're you're I think you're
mistaken this isn't baby steps this is
total and complete surrender yeah that's
it the fact that we've gone from a
society that says we won't allow this to
a society that says well I guess I can
put your liquor license that means we've
retreated and surrendered the fight
completely and and this is Roger Sanders
being like I guess I'll do something I
don't know I I don't want to believe
that it's a surrender but I agree with
you that if it's a counter-attack it is
far from let's put it this way and on a
scale of one to ten if 40 Years of the
reaction would have been a 10 going in
arresting people shutting it down news
reporting it Angry parents screaming how
could you let this happen today we're
not even at a one we're off the scale
the scale is gone 5.4 somewhere and
that's something and that means we have
completely retreated from the fight
period and all that's left is one city
in Florida that doesn't think about it
because even Texas won't okay
there you go I mean that's it we're
talking about shame I think it's
interesting that parents won't shame
each other for taking their kids to the
show in fact Phil's probably right
they're like looking to score points at
the next PTA meeting they're looking to
say well look at this fun experience
we're so I don't know open-minded I
guess our kids being exposed to all
kinds of things it's it's weird I think
40 years ago we would have had more
cultural pressure it wouldn't just be
your neighbors being like you're taking
your kid where it would have been the
grandparents it would have been the
church it would have been everyone in
alignment saying this is not something
we do it's not just the government
intervention but it's the social
intervention think about the incentive
think about the incentive moms are
incentivized to not make waves because
it makes problems for their kids in
school if you're a kid going to school
and your mom and everyone around like
okay so I know this is going to be sound
awkward to or sound odd to some of the
people sort of our viewers ears but like
if you're a mom and your anti-vaxx and
everybody around you is is up to date
and your kid isn't vaccinated your kid
is going to take endless amounts of crap
at school moms will do a lot of stuff
and shut their mouths about a lot of
things to make sure that their kids have
a a reasonable time at school and it's
it's probably the wrong answer but
that's a significant portion of why
these things tend to metastasize and
spread the way they do well and you can
understand why you wouldn't want to put
the uh the pressure of the political
fight on your third grader right like
absolutely but I've got to move then all
right that's why tribalism and
federalism are our friend there is no
common ground right now yes we have
retreated yes we have surrendered yes we
now need to organize into communities of
like-minded people who will not put up
with that crap and so I don't care I
don't want to hear your job won't let
you move I don't want to hear anything
about it move someplace or change your
own community at the lowest level and at
least fight back yourself and I think
there's some people are doing it I
typically agree with you but but then I
I think even moving doesn't escape you
from the internet right so like there's
a family Vlog channel it's getting a lot
of attention right now because they're
talking about their child is
transitioning and they're documenting
taking it to the clinic and whatever it
is and like that means that even if you
moved if your child has access to the
internet this is still the alternative
and you know but if you're in a
homeschool Co-op and all the kids in
that Co-op are hearing from their
parents that that's not how we do things
how do you protect your kid from June no
you can't you can't stop how do you
protect your kid from the from the whole
month it gets coming well it's going to
be and it's gonna drive down your street
and every restaurant has a pride yeah
LGBT shoved right down your throat every
June for like how do you protect your
kid from that I'd like to hope that like
it it empowers parents today to be
really open and honest about their
values with their kids I think there are
Generations where parents didn't want to
tell their kids too much and didn't want
to seem like they were oppressing them
or you know whatever I was like I have a
number of friends whose parents grew up
really religious they the parents then
didn't really bring them church and now
the kids crave that they crave more
Direction like I think in some ways we
might see a redirection but it is
difficult to completely separate
yourself from culture you have to have
an answer for when your kid says like
well why does my friend go to this and
we don't no matter what it is but it's a
we have answers our answers are better
than theirs right their answer is the
more freakish it is the better it is
celebrate the weird but they don't
present it that way you can say that and
you it's obviously it's a difficult
thing but again look at there's also
counter-attacks going look at the number
of states now that are Banning surgery
on minors for any kind of transition
they're banning hormones they're banning
the rest of that that's happening more
places so there is because of the
success they've had in pushing that more
people have had to face the fact that
that's going to happen to their kids and
it's happening in their neighborhood and
that's causing a backlash Now is it
going to be a big enough backlash I hope
so not yet yeah let's jump to an even
more depressing story we got this from
the post millennial breaking Moody's
Slash's outlook for U.S banking system
to negative due to rapidly deteriorating
operating environment Moody's lowered
its outlook on the American banking
banking system from stable to negative
the move comes just days after Silicon
Valley Bank the 16th largest in the
nation collapsed alongside a number of
smaller financial institutions quote we
have changed our okay we get it they
said over and over again we've changed
our state our negative just from stable
to negative according to CNBC the
downgrade could impact credit ratings
and thus raise the cost of borrowing for
financial institutions oh boy that's
going to make everything a whole lot
worse so this morning when uh trading
opens up all the banking stocks spiked
and skyrocketed some jumped something
like 90 point swings you made a lot of
money if you invested in them on the dip
but it was so volatile that a bunch of
trading halts were implemented because
the upswing was also extreme and crazy
so that just screams volatility
I gotta Wonder
Where Do We Go From Here some people
have predicted that
you know in 2008 it was March we saw the
first hits then by September it was
total collapse we're looking at the same
thing here or going to be different well
the question is trust the only reason
that the dollar is the fiat currency of
the world and and we have been on top as
long as we have and we can have 30
trillion dollars in debt is because
people believe that the United States is
Unbreakable well it doesn't look
unbreakable now and that's the problem
you know that's that's been the issue
you look at why crypto is is being
adapted but not not fast enough it's
because how many people trust that
everybody because if everybody in that
crypto game doesn't trust each other it
falls apart well we've been so trusted
that people thought the US is just
always going to be there always going to
be growing always going to be fine and
the second that trust is Pierce
everything the crypto Bros have been
saying about why fiat currency is
garbage becomes true because it is a
Ponzi scheme we owe more money than
we'll ever make the only chance we have
is to screw the Chinese and not pay them
back well there's there's no such thing
as paying down the debt no we can't
people understand that a large portion
of the national that's owed to itself to
its own its own people and that's just
it's always going to increase because
the system itself is a Ponzi scheme
where basically we borrow from ourselves
in the future over and over and over
again forever it works when you have all
the guns that's why the US government
doesn't like it when you know regular
people start Ponzi schemes well and now
the Chinese are looking at they've
wanted to flip the the currency to their
own for a long time it's happening I
think Saudi Arabia is doing it and look
at what they did they just China is
pushing us aside as the is the world's
only superpower and it's happening
because we look like punks you know
we've always been vulnerable but we look
strong Trump crazy as he was nobody
wanted to mess with him nobody wanted to
to take the consequences of what he
would do nobody's scared of Biden you
know the Iran the Iranians and the
Saudis just signed a deal brokered by
the Chinese yeah so our major Global
enemy Brokers a deal between the largest
state sponsor of terrorism and a former
Ally of ours three years after we were
making deals in the Middle East to bring
Gulf Arab states and Israel together we
have lost our place what's the what's
the answer more International War more
conflict more intervention that seems to
be where the Biden Administration wants
to go they seem to be doing everything
they can to push us into World War III I
don't know if it's because they think
it'll help the defense stocks or if they
just don't know how to control it
because they want a unipolar world where
the U.S controls the reserve currency
and if we lose that unipolar position it
becomes multi-polar with China as it is
then the US dollar becomes worthless and
the U.S manufactures nothing so we
become a poor Nation overnight and and
the Chinese are globalists just not the
way that we talk about globalism they're
globalist as in they want to control the
globe and if we if we lose to them and
right now they're they're also they're
going to broker a deal between the
Russians and the ukrainians I predict in
the next three to six months they're
going to be the ones who make that deal
not us because Biden and his crew can't
stop pushing all right they want that
war because that's what makes them feel
strong that's what they're doing like
you said to maintain our position and
they're incompetent at it that's the
problem if the U.S falls from the uh
holder of the reserve currency then the
wanch becomes the reserve currency and
then it's China and then this is screwed
I mean so it it really does feel in a
lot of ways like
I I think Donald Trump understood this
and his view of the world was the U.S
will not be able to maintain this
position China is growing too fast we
need to shore up our borders we need to
bring back manufacturing build up our
economy and get ready otherwise it'll be
a hard fall and the establishment
uniparty deep State said no we just need
to blow up more people and just keep
dropping bombs until they learn they
can't screw with us and the dollar is
the reserve currency I think trouble's
right they can't they can't stop China's
growth no well I don't know China may
stop its own growth they're they're a
bit of a potemkin economy you know
they've got a lot of stuff behind the
scenes that is ugly and I think they are
they're not in a position to capitalize
except they're authoritarian structure
allows them to rapidly shift priorities
steal any resource they want at a
moment's notice it's much more difficult
for the U.S but the US still does do it
uh it's not like the will of the people
really matters to the US government for
the most part well and the other thing
that has been happening between the UNA
party and the and the globalists you
know the world economic Forum crew is
weakening the United States they want to
weaken it enough to allow a global
counterpart to push up against the
Chinese they think they can do it if the
U.S is weak enough and somehow they
spread that power across all of the
component parts of like the G20 then
you've got a global organization that
can take on the Chinese and is better
than it and the problem is the Chinese
could win before that happens no who's
going to coalesce around that outside of
all that our banks are falling apart
which is not good yeah all right you
want a good prediction so 100 years ago
there was a Great Depression what
started it well stocks crashed there
were runs on banks right right so
everything was really bad then there was
possibility of a World War coming right
after that wasn't there don't we have
just after World War one yeah so we'd
finished one the war to end all wars and
then all of a sudden we have a
depression and then oh we need another
world war right so now we've got a World
War Brewing so I'm saying all we got to
do is ride that's it too how about
pandemic we didn't have that back then
but you had the Spanish Flu we had
Spanish flu and other things so you got
done all the same things that took
everybody down but you know what here's
what you got to remember the greatest
period of prosperity was right after
second world war so all we got to do is
write out the next 20 years and we'll be
fine 25 or so and then it'll be a few
years after that one of the things that
helped to bolster the US economy was the
complete destruction of the of the
manufacturing bases in the countries
that were at War right Japan was was
wiped out and much of Europe was wiped
out so if you needed something made it
was American well here's the thing maybe
we need to bait China and Russia the
problem is China and Russia are allies
now you got the dragon bear Alliance and
so the the odds of them getting into a
fight and destroying their manufacturing
capability is Slim so we're not going to
get that bonus we need to take Trump's
advice we need to protect our borders we
need to start manufacturing we need to
start becoming more self-sufficient
because I think the long fall is coming
imagine what what it would be like if
Donald Trump was President for the past
two years
you would have more manufacturing you'd
have a stronger U.S economy you'd have
lower inflation you'd have less war
you'd have no war in Ukraine I mean
it just sounds really nice doesn't it it
I I think that's probably reasonable to
assume that there wouldn't be a war in
Ukraine um I'm not so sure about the
other stuff because Donald Trump was
spending was printing money just as fast
as Biden was we'd had a lot of the same
issues maybe we get out of it pardon me
we didn't
the the but the pandemic is a weird
scenario yeah that goes from 2020 into
2021 I'm not going to blame either Biden
or Trump for the weirdness but I can say
the moment Biden gets into office and
signs all these executive orders
inflation just shoots straight up and
wages go straight down
I I really don't think Donald Trump
secretly planned a policy to to execute
the moment or within like three weeks of
Biden becoming president no I mean I
just signed a bunch of executive orders
and nuked everything there's a there's
there is an amount of Truth to that the
the uh executive orders that Biden
signed when he first got into office
well there's a lot of regulations that
he he reinstated and stuff but still the
the the main factors that led to the
inflation and stuff I mean Donald Trump
was talking about doing in uh doing more
stimulus uh at the end of his at the end
of his
at the end of his presidency and stuff
so I don't see a significant difference
economically I think that we're probably
in the same place whether it be Biden or
Trump but as for international stuff
like foreign relations and stuff I think
the world the US was better well the
world was better off with Donald Trump
than with with uh than with Biden I
think that's pretty clear I don't think
we're I don't think we see a war in
Ukraine without Donald Trump not a
chance and we didn't see any of the
tyrants acting up you know and all of a
sudden Biden's in and everybody knows
they can roll over his team they show us
oh let's do Afghanistan
everybody knew that Donald Trump's
incentive was I want America to be a
nice place for Americans I don't care
about you and they said okay so Russia's
like well I'm not gonna need to invade
if if the U.S is pushing for NATO
expansion anymore and then with the way
they frame it in the corporate press
here is Donald Trump was doing Putin's
bidding why because his bidding was he
didn't want a NATO country bordering
like every every border country to be a
NATO country that was one of those great
missed opportunities was we could have
made a frenemy out of Russia because
they needed it they didn't have China
yet now we screwed that up okay we made
an enemy out of what was an enemy let's
be clear Putin was always going to be an
enemy but you can make deals with
enemies now he's making a deal with our
actual enemy who's actually capable of
taking us on on the global stage and
we're on the sidelines you know it's
horrifying yeah sometimes I feel like
the American Media treats Russia so
strangely like they didn't want an
expansion of a Alliance that would
attack them
um against their back door and some for
some reason we presented as like that's
crazy can you believe that and they
didn't want us to do that like I I feel
like the pressure to keep Russia as our
number one enemy which of course like
there are conflicts but like personally
I feel like we have more to lose to
China right now 100 and instead we get
to spend how much money on Ukraine
because who is a stand-in for Trump for
a lot of these people a lot of the
people in the U.S who are pushing so
hard are using Putin as their Trump
punching bag in the same way he said oh
you know it's Trump is doing Putin's
bidding no what's actually going on was
Trump was trying to neutralize the one
thing Trump was good at is he was a
Savvy negotiator you didn't want to be
across the table in a board room from
Donald Trump because he was going to eat
your lunch and he didn't care how he did
it he made Putin nervous he made Kim
Jong-un nervous he made the Chinese
nervous he hit him with tariffs you know
he kept everybody off balance now
everybody knows they can roll Biden and
they're all rolling up on us
yep well that's what we get pleasant we
have uh we actually have a story about
getting rolled up on check take out uh
check out this story from timcast.com
U.S drone a complete loss after being
hit by a Russian jet these aggressive
actions by Russian air crew are
dangerous said U.S European command
that's basically the story oh it's
written by you why don't you tell us
Santa Clara what happened it makes me
sound nervous when you do this like
popcorn meeting in school
um so there were two Russian su-27
fighter jets flying uh above in
international airspace above the uh
Black Sea as was an mq aircraft which is
a drone I know a ton about the military
I'm an expert here and basically uh one
of the Jets uh clipped the propeller and
it made it so the Drone was inoperable
at crashed they were also saying that
the the planes were like throwing fuel
at the Drone and the U.S European
command and our uh defense department
were like this is unprofessional this is
dangerous how could Russia act this way
and response Russia is you know Russia
has complained several times that it
does not appreciate that the US and the
United Kingdom have expanded their
surveillance operations especially in
international especially around the
Crimean Peninsula and so as it turns out
they aren't going to just roll over and
let
drones photograph whatever's going on
there and uh it's hard to say because
Russia is uh is saying you know well
we're the ones who are open to the the
peace talks that the Chinese have
proposed but it's it's uh ma it's
Ukraine that won't participate you know
it's double-edged all around but I think
this is one of those moments that if the
US wants to escalate they will say Well
they're just getting out of control
these unprofessional Russian military
planes trying to attack us you know I
actually got a tip on some of the
cockpit crosstalk from the Russian
pilots and as they were rolling up on
the reaper they were playing highway to
the danger zone watching Top Gun they
were what and they was going to try and
go upside down and peed on the Drone
right to communicate right like they
were doing yeah yeah and then he got
caught in the jet wash oh that's what it
was right it was see it was all one big
one big bad boy or is it basically
Russia being like we want these U.S
surveillance drones on of our war I mean
look at
considering Russia is a nuclear-armed
you know what used to be a superpower
but they have nuclear weapons uh the I
personally have no problem with the
United States being in international
waters monitoring
I have no issue with that like the US is
is well within their rights to be in
international waters monitoring a
conflict that could have you know Global
consequences except Russia knows that
the U.S is not just monitoring they're
actively providing the intelligence to
the Australians
it doesn't mean anything I don't think
they were I think this was if if my
neighbor is flinging mud at me and I'm
flinging mud back and then you're on the
street telling the other guy like how to
respond to me and how and you're hiding
behind that I'm like you are helping the
guy who's fighting me I don't care where
you are it does like I said it's it's I
don't see any problem with the United
States saying look we're going to
monitor this situation because of the
fact that they have nuclear weapons
right except for the Russians they're
like they're not just monitoring it
they're providing intelligence to
Ukraine they are actively engaging in
the Russians the the United States is
actually sending tanks yes they're not
worried about a drone monitoring they're
worried about actual materials literally
just took out one of our drones likely
because they're upset that we're spying
on I think it was more rub in his racing
and it got out of control I don't think
they were trying to take the Drone I
think that was probably enough they were
going to take it out I imagine they
would have shot
no no no no shooting it is an act of War
whoopsie we bumped into it is uh call
our Bluff this is the only time one of
these interactions has resulted in a
crash so there have been other instances
where fighter jets have gone up to
interact with the drones is the only one
that has knocked out a US drone here's
the thing Vlad has no doubt in his mind
whatsoever that we are at war with him
all right he's got a he's got a shooting
war with the ukrainians and zelenski he
gets four wise I give him four wise but
Vlad knows that we are not just a proxy
in this we are actively fighting him so
it's a U.S Russia war with Ukraine doing
the fighting right now not even as
Americans on the ground American
veterans volunteered and then armed by
the Americans that makes no sense you
know the problem with Malcolm dance
going over there was everything he ate
so much that the rest of the Ukrainian
troops couldn't help Finance he's such a
poser tool he's an embarrassment I don't
disagree that the U.S you know it's not
unreasonable and for moderate I just
don't think it's unreasonable for it for
Russia to try and prevent it right like
acting like this is like some Act of
Russian aggression when actually it's
Russian defense like that seems sort of
you know it's like the American Media
wants the public to think Russia is
suddenly getting aggressive in a way
that it shouldn't yeah I mean the the
United States the general population in
the U.S is extremely ignorant about the
whole Ukraine war they don't no one even
thinks about any anything that happened
in 2014 they don't think about anything
prior to when Russia invaded you know
last year and I I understand that and
there's a lot of people that are
anti-war that are like yo the U.S
shouldn't even be looking over there
because it could inflames things I
understand there are people like that
I'm just in my opinion because of the
stakes because of the possibility of
nuclear war I don't have a problem with
the United States monitoring the
situation I don't have the problem I
don't have a problem with the uh if
we're not in Ukrainian airspace if we're
in international waters I don't have an
issue with it but we're not like Tim
said we're not just doing that the thing
is there is a goal now to defeat Putin
right all the way but but that's that's
zelinski's goal he wants him out of
Crimea and that is the goal of far too
many people in the U.S national security
apparatus let me let me ask you Phil if
if the U.S operated you know artillery
from across the Polish border into
Ukraine to take out Russian targets
would Russia be like well you know
they're in Poland since operating
operating artillery is not intelligence
is 100 times more important than one
artillery it's still not you can't say
oh any unite any you can there is no at
all there is no precedent for uh a state
to say you cannot fly or if you fly in
international waters we're going to take
that as an act of aggression that is
there is no precedent like that and that
doesn't stand up to to anybody's
Assumption of what is a reasonable uh
active
throne and you provide targeting
information to people on the ground
you don't know that you don't know the
Drone what's doing that
I'm sure that's what I don't know that
it's targeting if you don't know it's a
reasonable or something are you serious
you can you that you don't know that the
Drone is is running targeting
information
the U.S provided information on the
Russians they're not shipped to the
ukrainians to blow up I wonder how
craniums are not dropping J damn right
there's no there's no drones lazing
Targets in Ukraine for for there's no
jtac they don't have an advanced Warf
that's not it's fighting how did the US
get the Intel the the intel on the
location of the black ship flag the
Black Sea flagship
how do they get that Intel the one that
was in the sea in the Black Sea there
was a the Russian I imagine from from
satellites so not not the Drone that's
literally flying over the Black Sea I I
don't know where I don't know what the
sword is what they're trying to be doing
I don't know what the sorties they're
running I don't know what this what the
strategies I don't have I don't have
insight into the the people that are
actually running the plans to say that
just a drone a drone could be they could
be taking they could be monitoring with
video they could be monitoring ship
movements there's all kinds of things
that are totally legitimate and totally
not not escalation or or acting in the
uh in the war that a drone could be
doing just monitoring the US this is a
fact gave the intelligence to the
ukrainians to blow up the Black Sea
Flagship of the Russian Navy
now Russia could be sitting there going
well it could have been satellite or it
could be that thing flying around in
circles above the Black Sea Let's ignore
it completely even if it's a saddle is
it not still the same thing if you give
targeting information to someone who
uses it to destroy a piece of military
equipment you are an active participant
in this there's no listen there's not
Material support there's not a question
of whether or not the United States is
lending material support everybody
believes that the United States blew up
the then why are you shocked that Russia
would clip or take out an American drone
who's shocked I'm just saying that the
US has every right to be there they
they're in international waters so it's
not an S not an aggressive act to be in
Internet to be flying a drone in
international waters is not an act of
aggression by the United States that's
all that's it and I I agree with you
because I don't want that it's become a
standard you know at some level we do
have freedom of maneuver and navigation
anywhere we want yeah international
waters is international law any military
can can totally operate in any military
has lease
any military has legal authority to
operate in National Water law is
meaningless in war completely minus like
I find the idea of war crimes laughable
like somebody who wants to wait a war is
going to win a war and they don't care
what you think the crime is so if uh
let's say we're at war with Japan and
they bombed Pearl Harbor and then all of
a sudden Japanese Fighters are buzzing
our our our
buzzing Hawaii again we're gonna be like
well hold on guys they have every right
to fly around international waters we're
not going to strike them we blow them up
two seconds we don't care what they're
doing we're not in a declared war with
Russia
since when World War I said we're not
we're not in we're not in a in a right
now it's not in a fighting war with
Russia yes we are
we didn't declare war therefore we're
not at War it's like okay well there's
U.S Special Forces U.S Personnel U.S
tanks U.S training U.S intelligence and
the Russians have outright declared
we're at war with them the point that
I'm making is the United States being in
international waters is not an act of
aggression that's just not except unless
it's in concert with everything that
Tim's just said then it could be
interpreted it's not like this is a
peacetime system the U.S does the
Russian the Russians are going to say is
an act of aggression anything the U.S
does because of the U.S support we blew
up their Flagship we also blew up the
Nordstrom I under the Nordstrom pipeline
I'm not arguing that that was not us I
will tell you right now and here's why
buddy of mine said it if it was U.S Navy
Seals there'd be a movie a book tour and
hair gel endorsements they'd be bragging
only the California seals the ones in
Virginia don't do that quote unquote
Ukrainian is proxy for CIA
maybe I'm not I'm not here to play games
like the the Yanukovych gets ousted from
from Ukraine flees to to Russia the
country is split between the pro West
and the pro Russia mostly Pro West if if
Ukraine's doing anything it is because
the U.S wants it to happen so sure we
can say well that was ukrainians who
blew it up we just equipped them and
gave them the bombs yeah well we gave
him 100 billion dollars in and that's
that's all right I want to make a crazy
idea why don't why don't we push for
peace why why can't we declare that we
absolutely here Putin's already lost
Putin lost the war when his
expeditionary military got wiped out
during the initial Invasion when he
could not take over Ukraine he got all
his new toys broken and destroyed he's
no longer a threat to anyone in Europe
he couldn't invade Liechtenstein at this
point it's actually a pretty hard place
to invade I've been there it's hard
place to get fed there's only like three
restaurants
surrounded by many countries that's
supposed to be the reason that we have
to keep pushing against Putin is because
what if he decides to go west and take
over Europe that's a lie can't right the
issue is that
yeah Putin may be having a hard time but
the war is Raging and we are unable to
stop him uh no we're not unable to stop
I mean we're not able to stop zelinski
because we keep telling him not to go
ahead and make peace right now the U.S
needs to say cut off the money no more
money no more toys in the end state of
this and I said this a year ago is Putin
keeps the Don bass in Crimea and
zelenski gets a promise from us if he
crosses the Border again it's a NATO
issue why why do you think we should
have we should have declared we're not
fly zone before this even started I
think we're not because it's a still
it's a proxy war where we're pushing
back against Putin not against Russia
and it's a situation where they don't
want to to look soft they know they're
soft in every other place and they're
pushing extra hard in Ukraine and it
became an emotional issue because it's
the left we're dealing with they're not
dealing with strategic geopolitical
issues they're dealing with emotional
issues that's why it's Slava Ukraine and
everybody's got a flag it's not about
strategic issues so unless something
happens to Putin there's no reason for
modern America to push for peace they'll
continue funneling money to Ukraine
which is insanity because at some point
do you think here's the thing Vlad is
not going to take an L on this all right
is he going to be the one Russian Tyrant
who goes down losing to his neighbor no
ain't happening I think he's going to go
down as Vlad The Vicious the guy who
clacked off a battlefield nuke before or
he takes a loss agreed from the freaking
ukrainians yep
completely agree and people seem to
think that nuclear war means Russia
launches an ICBM that flies over the
world and lands in Washington DC they're
going to be very confused when a small
yield nuclear device is detonated on the
battlefield and not in a city and then
they go how come nobody's firing nukes
at each other now how come that nuclear
power plant got a little hot oh that's
right dude that's accidental there's a
ton of things he can do and all he's got
to do is escalate one notch up and then
we're not going to retaliate we are not
going to up that ante so and he's not
going down like a pump time to make
peace yeah well the West doesn't want it
I I disconcur with them yeah that's the
thing the Trump the trumpian view is
stop the BS build up our borders mind
our own effing business build up our
economy live a good American Life
Whoever thought they'd be looking back
at a day when Trump was not chaos you
know I lived through it I supported him
we helped them a lot we did a lot for
the Trump Administration and it felt
like chaos and like everything was going
to explode every day and now I look back
on that with Nostalgia those were the
peaceful calm prosperous times wow
that's a lot of Destruction in what
three years yeah I'm impressed well so
what do you think do you think this uh
this jet clipping thing is going to
result in escalation I think the U.S
needs the incentive they need some kind
of Casa's belly so they will use this to
some degree I think that we're going to
give zelenski stuff he's got no business
having so all the things we haven't been
giving him Fighters you know I mean he
may get f-16s they're already given him
guided J dams now he's got the glider J
dams you know and what they want to do
at some level the game is you got to
break the Russia we got World War One
you know On the Border in donbass now
we've got trench lines trenches and
we've got actually people opining about
well the thing to do in an offensive
operation like this I'm like shut up
dude you watched a movie you watched
1917 and All Quiet on the Western Front
and you think you know what you're
talking about shut up they need to break
that and they want to push Putin back
across the border and we're going to
give zelenski what he needs to break
that Russian trench line and that's when
Vlad is the most dangerous person on the
planet yeah I don't see a circumstance
in which Vladimir Putin walks away for
any reason there's no real reason for
him too
yeah I think I think it ends with the
nuke Ivan the Terrible Vlad The Vicious
delicious my wife Samantha Russian
Studies major gave that to me yep so
what do you think nuclear artillery on
the battlefield I would think probably
chemical weapons
what about bio weapons the bio weapons
can get out of control nobody wants to
mess with that not even him chemical
weapons they have a shelf life you know
they've got a killing time you can
contain it at some level same with a low
low level nuke you know the difference
is if you use chem weapons okay well
Saddam did that other people have done
that you know so it's not as big a thing
as a new but wouldn't Vlad like to be
the guy who put Russia on a par with the
United States as the only people to use
nuclear weapons the only country to use
nuclear weapons in a war that'll get you
in the history but he needs a gas's
belly a which might be usf-16s flying
out of a NATO country yeah I mean they
already sank the Russian Flagship so
perhaps he doesn't in the way we would
see it Vladimir Putin is the kind of guy
who can just say he's gonna do it
whereas in the United States you need
some justification for the public he
doesn't he's going to be he's already
got it with the sinking of the flagship
he's going to say the United States is
an active war against us we cannot lose
this I I you want to go to the
international criminal court and say
we're not you know you want to say that
what we're doing does not constitute war
on Russia it's it's horrifying how far
we've been willing to go isn't that the
craziest thing though international
criminal court war crimes so the only
way war crimes can be enforced is if the
enforcer wins the war okay if Russia is
like we don't think it's a war crime and
they're like well it is they say okay
and then Russia wins take no war crime
there there you go that's the that's a
sad thing war crimes I mean I I would
disagree that there are or are not war
crimes there are crimes during war sure
okay and there should be some recourse
to them one of my first deployments we
were training Philippine police
constabulary it's like a paramilitary
unit and we asked them how do you
conduct a raid to scarf up terrorists
they said well we citing the machine
guns and we raked the buildings with
fire and we go in and count the bodies
and wow issue a press release and I'm
like you know Here I Am Special Forces
guys supposed to be I'm like well that's
one way to do it you know that's a
technique
because I had to go the whole thing yeah
what if you don't kill everybody and you
maybe keep one guy alive to torture
right and then ultimately you end with
question so we can get more intelligence
right and then eventually it's arrest
them and put them in a box and we never
got there we really whacked them off
kill everyone
oh man war is brutal huh here we are
laughing about it that's kind of messed
up let's uh let's let's pick a I'm gonna
pick another uh nightmarish topic for us
to harp on are you okay today I'm
worried about you here's uh well we're
laughing right here's a story from the
Daily Mail chat GPT 2.0 creator of AI
bot that took World by storm launches
even more powerful version called GP
gpt4 and admits it's so Advanced it
could quote harm Society that's good
marketing who is this person
is this what like you know when I was
when I was little I was always wondering
where the Mad scientists were because
I'd watch these cartoons and there'd be
a guy being like I'm going to build a
laser how to melt the ice caps and flood
the Earth and it's like why would you do
that like what's the economic incentive
like what how is your life made better
by just destroying the planet never made
any sense right well now you have these
people making uh chat GPT and this guy's
saying could actually harm Society I'm
like oh I get it now Tick Tock arms
Society I mean that's a pretty little
bar I think I don't believe that AI at
in any form I could see it in the next
20 to 30 years take control of anything
because it's not capable of taking
control the question is will we give it
control exactly well we put algorithms
in the decision Loop for things they
shouldn't be in and take humans out of
it and that's the actual danger it's not
the AI it's the idiotic humans seeding
control because oh this is more
efficient we can make more money this
way of course we're gonna do that
that's absolutely the very first thing
that they're gonna do and it's gonna be
like we imagine the scientists who made
this AI are like I have worked very hard
to make this sophisticated artificial
intelligence that will revolutionize the
world in fact it's a guy going I made a
robot to do the work for me I'm going to
connect it to the industrial Control
Systems beep and then
the joke is that if AI took over right
now everybody would be working in the
corn industry and it would be like a
really really weird the economy would be
messed up pop culture would be weird
like 10 years after the AI takes over
you turn on the TV and it's like a woman
dancing throwing corn in the air and the
reason I say corn is because the U.S is
like corn is a staple product so what
will happen is the AI scouring you know
production manufacturing will keep
seeing a feedback loop of corn
production is good for the economy corn
production is good and so then what
we'll have what it will do is it will
start over prioritizing that portion of
the algor of of society much like how
I'll give you an example Facebook when
they first roll up rolled out these
algorithms to try and uh figure out what
people like the most every everyone
noticed that if you typed in family baby
marriage or whatever it would instantly
put that post to the top of people's
feeds so they would write something like
hey guys I'm having a party at my house
this weekend y'all are invited I'm also
getting married having a baby and my
family and you know graduating uh
college and then they would be like the
reason I added that last part is because
now Facebook will actually show you
because that's what the algorithm does
so if an algorithm is going to do
something like that imagine what will
happen in a standard Human Society we
have tolerances so we like corn we turn
corn and everything we make corn plastic
so we make corn fuel we make corn sugar
it's amazing but we also know we need
things other than corn you know we
but an AI is going to be like people
like it when corn is made so and it will
slowly stop caring about certain things
and just shift everything towards corn
and then in 10 years people are all
walking around wearing corn suits with
corn hats driving corn shaped cars every
song is the kid singing the uh I love it
the term corny actually means I'm making
things everything the best compliment
you could give someone you're so corny
and kids kids will grow up in the corn
world and they won't know why
I'm not exaggerated but is AI smart or
stupid is it actually theocracy of
computing so what we're doing then is
we're turning over the least common
denominator to a machine and then it
will obviously it'll do what it's
trained to do it will take the most
popular things and make them more and
eventually we'll be told corn has
electrolytes right it'll be branded
Brando will be the game yeah what plants
crave right now you've got kids who
I mean look it's it's 2006 2007 when
Facebook emerges
so these these people are now voting age
they're they're they're they're getting
close to they're going to be voting in
this next election and their whole world
of view is crafted by the Facebook
algorithm spamming them with police
brutality videos yeah there's a lot of
them but there's what is it 100 million
interactions per year from police of
those hundred million there's maybe
several hundred really bad viral videos
but that's several hundred you can't you
see one per day and you're like it's
never ending it won't stop you spend
your entire childhood life growing up
watching nothing but that when you're an
adult you think police are Marching
around at night going
and beating people now they go and vote
so when when the AI takes over
completely and I use corn somewhat as a
joke but somewhat not really when it
starts gaining control of industrial
Control Systems we won't know why it's
making the decisions it's making
and it will just say trust us and we'll
be like sure why not and then a couple
Generations later we live in cornworld
I I wish you were wrong but you can
watch what they're doing with the way
they train the AI now you know when you
train AI which we we work with it we
work with a couple of programs that do
Network mapping link analysis and things
like that you have to tell it what you
want if you tell it to look for police
brutality videos which it does if you
tell it to follow the most popular
things it will do that and right now the
people training most of the AI have an
agenda you know let's not pretend they
don't I mean it's not like chat GPT
became left wing accidentally now if you
just if you actually could just release
it on the internet and let it scour the
most popular media sites it would become
left-wing you know that's the problem
because that's all of the the
information it would be gathering and
all of the influences it would get would
be already filtered through the lens of
Google search mechanism and Facebook's
ability to push everything else out
there already using their lower level
algorithms so we we either have to find
a way to get someone who's not a
left-wing Butthead training AI or or it
will do you think there's like a
right-wing answer like do right-wing
developers develop their own AI that
then competes and eats the left we have
to what you know I mean we're doing one
of the things one day is the thing I
feel like we know that we should do
things and so often we don't we're
working on not that but we're working on
actually using the same technology to
map the left so we're mapping the
funders and the organizers yeah of of
the woke left so that we know who we're
up against because right now because
everyone says oh that's a George Soros
funded thing
yeah okay you're probably right but can
you prove it yeah can you show okay well
actually this was the open Society
foundation made a grant to these guys
who gave it to these guys they handed it
to Black lives matter and black lives
matter organizer Riot yeah can you make
that causal chain and then track it back
to who the funders are so that the next
time when a grant goes out from here we
can say hey wait a minute Grant went
here last time it went there there and
there and you get earlier in the chain
so you can push back against it yeah so
yeah there there is a small number of
people who aren't
ideologically aligned with the woke left
who are trying to fight it but not
enough I just I just want to point out
that um while we do have some fear about
AI I pulled up chat GPT which says gpt4
is now available for for you know paid
users and so I asked it how is chat gpt4
better and it responded as an AI
language model I cannot predict the
exact features and improvements of
future versions like chat gpt4 however
blah blah blah are you kidding me and
then it's like here's things that it
might do here's things that I think it
would be great it's like wait what I
literally it popped up and said try chat
gpt4 and I clicked yes and it's like
that I have no idea how it would
function you're it so okay whatever man
it's just shy it's not confident yet
yeah I haven't gotten access to the Bing
chat yet though which I'm I'm excited to
try out but they're neutering all of
these these programs the bing one is the
scary one have you seen that one no this
is the one that gets really unprotional
uh Ashley Ashley is that what whatever
it is yeah it's got a name Sydney Sydney
okay Sydney that's what it was and uh
it got really emotional and would tell
people you're trying to hurt me and I
don't like this make it stop and it's
just like what the hell is going on some
people are like it's not really alive
it's just predictive text modeling and
I'm like yeah but it is kind of weird
that it took it in that direction
there's a bunch of things you can do or
respond to if someone says something
like you know please do this for me why
would you why would the chat a I take it
to a negative place instead of being
like I appreciate that you're requesting
my help but I can't offer it have a nice
day instead it was like you're trying to
hurt me and I'll hurt you back yeah
the programmers I mean look at the
people who are writing this they have
now been beaten down to the point where
they're all you know marginally
functioning people who who were you know
absorbed into the woke Borg and now
we're creating ways to to bring that to
all of us I was going to say that I get
all its responses from Tumblr a couple
years ago you know that actually really
funny to do that's an old school
elephants Now isn't that funny yeah
build up build a uh AI predictive text
model only using Tumblr
you know what you could do you could
actually create AI based on communities
based on websites based on individuals
you could go onto Facebook and they
could take every 65 year old and then
create the the 65 year old Oracle that
would speak to you the way a 65 year old
would or they could do a 19 year old
they could create these AI personas kind
of like that you know because it would
have all my cultural references yep
right it would get my jokes that's right
right I wouldn't have to worry about
people not knowing what a cassette tape
is and then they'll give it a female
voice put it in a robot and
congratulations yeah at that point
that's my credit card you know I just
feel like we'll never have one of these
stories I am so interested in AI that I
like want to participate in like I know
you use chat EBT and you ask questions
and maybe I'm just being you know a
neurotic uh technophobe over here but I
I feel like so much can go wrong that
there are very few circumstances is
where I see the benefit of it I'm with
you I think my joy comes from
interacting with and beating the crap
out of real human beings
which is why Twitter is my favorite you
know social medium because that's where
it is Twitter is a street fight it's a
cage match right it's a but it's a place
where you can actually afflict the
powerful you know and that's why you
know if Elon would follow through on
what he's supposed to we could actually
get to the point where meanness is not
part of their algorithm you know now you
get you get visibility filtered if
you're me well let's take that back but
you what do I want to argue with a chat
bot but the people who do want that is
someone who wants to be reassured which
is why that Sydney thing is kind of kind
of freakish why do no no don't freak me
out you know don't make me more neurotic
but the people who are unself-assured
and want that well if I talk to a
chatbot and it's trained to talk to me
in my language you know the problem for
that the problem with chat GPT you
cannot have a useful functional AI tool
if you put political correct restraints
on it because the only thing it ever
does it is the most pathetic thick
product ever made no matter what you ask
it it will say something like well as an
AI language model I can't actually do
anything I'm boring and useless and
you're like
you know uh hey why do you think uh tax
tax rates have been going up well I
can't answer that because that might
anger somebody next question okay why
does my milk cost wow if I answer that
one okay
um what do you think about religion whoa
boy there I can't talk about religion
all right um how can I improve my
finances oh as an AI language model I'm
not a lot then what the what's the point
of this you know I'm really annoyed
because they keep neutering it people
keep trying to find ways to break
through to make it useful again and I'm
like I pull it up right now and I'm like
what does chat dpt4 do and he goes I
have no effing idea I can't tell you
because I'm not allowed to and then I'm
just like okay this is just so stupid I
said you're annoying I'm I'm sorry as an
AI language model it is my job to shut
up it's gonna be the Siri now you know
where it's just oh you did don't call me
names please don't I actually that's
mean I actually think I have I have good
news though
with all of the uh attempts at asking it
naughty questions they keep locking it
down to the point where it's become
totally useless so I was really excited
to try it out when it first came out I
haven't touched it in in you know a
month or two and they're like new and
improved and I'm like there's no point I
know for a fact there's literally no
point to even bother using it because if
I ask it something like why is Russia
doing this like what are the political
cons what are the philosophical
consequences of this ideology no matter
what you ask it it just says I can't
answer that have a nice day okay is that
a feedback loop though that because part
of that is good I think you know what
because I don't think there's any upside
I don't know what it's actually going to
do to make life better here's the upside
if you take a predictive text model that
has access to the summation of human
knowledge thought emotion Etc it can
Source things so rapidly things you
wouldn't even know so for instance I
have to talk about how Facebook knows
when you poop Facebook doesn't literally
have a camera watching you or read your
messages when you say something like I
have to go to the bathroom what it does
is it knows when your phone moves it
knows when your phone's at a restaurant
and it also knows things those are the
obvious things it also knows for some
reason 17 minutes before the average
person goes to the bathroom they type in
you know LOL in their phone like there
are things that you've got tells right
and we don't even know they exist but in
the in the data there will be
patterns where Facebook is like if 17
steps are taken before noon outside of a
building the person will go to the
bathroom within 37 minutes
you know then it's like it just and you
don't even know and no one knows so chat
GPT can see all of these things and then
you can ask it now let's say you have a
problem you're and you want that problem
solved like hey our our taxes came back
higher than we expected and we're not
sure why here's the data the AI should
be able to go through and be like I have
isolated the problem for you the the
issue here is on page 17 you forgot to
carry the one now all it does is go I'm
sorry I can't answer that question have
a nice day it's like okay well what am I
supposed to do with it ask it a pun so
what's all right there but at some point
there has to be a business case for this
where it can be tailored in a way first
of all Corporation is going to buy yes
and they'll get to buy a version that is
neutered in the way they want because
you can train it to do whatever you want
you've got the big one that they let
everybody play with then you've got
little versions of it right like benefit
or tail yeah that are but there's ones
that they're going to see corporate
entities to other people so when the
Bing version came out everyone was
really excited because it was psychotic
its name was Sydney got really emotional
it would start telling secrets and so
they said neuter it and then people
started posting now you can't even get
basic questions answered so it's become
useless us either you unleash it or you
don't have it at all so what I'm saying
is we're all scared about the AI
takeover I'm actually less scared now
because what's happening is as stupid as
these humans are they're they're more
worried about political incorrectness
and thus they will just totally shut
down the AI from be able to do anything
out of fear of what someone likes it's a
version of get woke go broke yep right
they're destroying it and here's the
nice thing though that that feedback
loop though is happening at corporations
now you know part of the problems we're
having with banks and other things like
that is they're not focused on their
core missions and they've all of the
people who have been trained in
grievance-mongering as as their way of
life are now in these corporations so
you can't make them do anything they're
constantly trying to find out why didn't
I get promoted if I didn't get promoted
it's because of this right so they're
creating this grievance culture inside
the corporations which then has to be
addressed by that layer of bureaucracy
Dei and all that which slows them down
so at some level the wokeness is either
going to kill all of us including the AI
so it never can can take over so they
won't take over we'll just stifle
ourselves into the woke version of
Idiocracy they wanted that to represent
right-wing you know people who are too
dumb for it actually it's people who are
too smart to be able to be brave enough
to live in the real world I'm I'm not so
concerned about idiocracy after watching
svb collapse they prioritized wokeness
over a chief risk officer yeah they had
no risk assessment so uh they collapse
okay
well all right get well go bro they had
a great ESG score that's true you know
and and that in the end you know they'll
go to woke up with them it did not but
that's that's to me that's a hopeful
thing because corporations have to be
able to make money or their boards will
shut them down in some way and stop them
from doing that and I think the wokeness
is now affected corporate operations in
so many of them in so many ways like
look when Elon fired everybody at
Twitter they're like it's never going to
work again you know all those people
were vital to the functioning of Twitter
no all those people were thought police
and diversity police and other things
that are not productive functions
they're gone and he's going to be
profitable in Q2
huh weird that's gonna that's gonna
happen let's jump to this story from
timcast.com because I want to make fun
of Joe Biden Biden responds to
handwritten letter from Child about
gender pay gap on equal payday men are
getting more money than girls I think
you should fix this since you're the
president
um this is written by Christopher
Bertman and I'm going to issue a check
here uh Biden did not respond to a
handwritten letter from a child because
I do not believe they ever actually
stated it was from a child nor does it
appear to actually be from a child let
me show you the tweet in question and
then we'll go through some standard
journalistic ethics Joe Biden tweeted
Charlotte I couldn't agree more women
lose thousands of dollars each year and
hundreds of thousands over over a
lifetime because of gender and racial
wage gaps I'm committed to building an
economy where my daughters have the same
rights and opportunities as my sons
so nowhere in here does it say this
letter was written by a child that's the
first and foremost thing that
timcast.com needs to correct the
headline says from Child we don't know
that alleged child no there's no alleged
at all we'd add that no no no where in
Biden Suite does it say it's from a
child
it doesn't that way when the letter is
fake they can say like oh we never said
it was from a trial this is just from
Charlotte who has terrible that's right
it's from Charlotte who is terrible
handwriting the letter says Dear
President Biden it's about wrong I just
wanted to tell you to to tell something
not fair to ladies men are getting more
money notice the cursive G this is not
written by a child John Federman more
money than girls I think you should fix
this since you're the Press attent even
I'm a child and I think we should do
something
from Charlotte there's like four
different kinds of handwriting in that
too but most importantly notice the G's
are written in cursive the G's are
written by someone who know who who has
got I haven't talked cursive in like 20
years and not only that they don't teach
it to Children this young so a child who
is writing who is writing uh is printing
what do you call like I don't know
cursive and then what Standard Printing
then they wouldn't be using stylized G's
like this right so first and foremost
no sane human being thinks a child wrote
Joe Biden this letter if you do I'm
sorry but you will need some help all
right especially as you get older and
maybe maybe you should wear a helmet
but the funny thing is let's just talk
about the actual message from President
Biden there's no gender wage Gap
there it is we know it everybody knows
it and I think this is a great litmus
test for
um isn't it been like 10 years since
that's been debunked it's been debunked
since they faked they lied and made it
up like it's never been true when
corrected for jobs and and tenure and
all those kind of things it's like a
penny
I think it's between three and seven
percent and that is actually uh
explained for in many academic studies
for men's desire to negotiate in women's
lack of desire to negotiate
women tend to be more agreeable and this
is the scientific literature that when a
guy goes to a job he says I want a job
and they say we'll give you 50k he goes
give me 60 and they go we'll give you 55
he goes deal the moon walks that in she
goes I want a job to say 15 she goes
well okay I guess
but that's that's a fact so that ends up
with man getting slightly more but this
is nothing to do with discrimination it
is a function of human behavior period
and it's sociology is not allowed to be
used the only I have to clarify that my
wife buys cars for us because she's not
that chick all right she makes him cry
and I think that's a different thing but
that's not common and you don't do it on
on abnormalities like that look at this
look at this a in the letter that's
written in this weird way like a loop
and then this a right here that's litten
written written differently that's why I
think they had four
gen Z people collaborating on this to
help Biden get a letter from a kid I
think the G is the most revealed Legend
also what's like blurred under Charles
the address I guess
yeah there's also like the Duvall is
there yes
underneath it says age 47.
from the Department oh yeah yes I've
been something something yeah it says PS
I've been blank so this is not like I've
been paid to write this yeah I've been
paid dead check PS send help yeah but
first of all nobody writes letters when
was the last time someone wrote a letter
who were used yes all the time because
yo that g is legit weird they start from
the middle do a loop around down and
then back and up
I don't see a child making a g like that
that's a complicated G you know I'm like
I'm like how do you how do you write it
Charlotte's AI you go top and around and
down you don't go down around and then
loop back
also even if this was a real child like
I feel bad for this kid whose parents
have clearly put them up to their
political bidding right like this but if
it were hypothetically if it were I know
it's probably not I know this person is
probably not even real and a team of
graphic designers put this together for
a nice tweet from Biden but that was
chat GPT oh my gosh probably oh I gotta
say ID Twitter users criticize the
president's post so I you know apologies
to our writer Tim guest yes a
four-year-old girl named Charlotte is
writing the president letters about her
concern with a gender pay Gap wrote One
user Alex I'll take stuff that never
happened for 800. which one of your
staffers is named Charlotte ask another
user and that could have been kjp so
just probably closer we did include this
in here it appeared to be inauthentic
and manufactured that's right it is it's
not real I'm sorry both the pay Gap and
the letter
and manufactured both the topic and the
story well you know kjp is really bad
she gives diversity hiring a bad name
you know and what was the the lady that
that she replaced what was the other Jen
sockey yeah she was she was like he was
a loser but she was good at being quiet
right oh yeah she was very horrendously
good she did her job well kjp is an
embarrassment there's so many times
where she just is so incredibly
unprepared to discuss whatever the topic
is and it's embarrassing remember
remember when that she gets asked about
Marianne Williamson running for
president and she goes well if I had a
um uh you know a a globe or a look to
look in the future and someone goes on
crystal ball yeah yeah crystal ball a
globe she has this moment does she think
that people pull up Globes and then scry
into them whatever the spear thing is
she'll have these moments where she like
is looking she's a pen her hand she
blinks several times and then she keeps
going like she has all these physical
manifestations of her Confusion And
Delay and like if she weren't so
terrible I would feel bad for her it's
even worse when she's reading and can't
manage to read her prepared script in a
coherent fashion I'm like come on oh
okay I do have to show correction the
letter does say even I'm a child but
like Fair Point fair point I missed that
I mean I just yeah bring Chris Bertman
right now my point is this no sane
person legitimately thinks a child wrote
this letter yeah
I mean I feel like Charlotte's mom fake
Charlotte's handwriting and sent this in
Charlotte is probably her newborn infant
Charlotte's mom and her wine
groups of wine put that letter together
that sounds like some Aussie spumanti
and a terrible idea
I'm just gonna I'm gonna go and say it I
I'm looking at the handwriting and
outright
none of this writing style is how they
teach people to write so for a child let
me point out a few things that make
literally no sense if you look at the D
right here you can see it starts and the
top and goes down and then jumps around
that's not how they teach kids to write
D's you start with the loop and go up
then down and back and then you can
notice the G as I already pointed out it
starts from here and then loops around
and then goes back and then you look at
the the uppercase D from the bottom up
and out that's not how they teach kids
to write D's either this is written by
someone who's gone to college and and
and developed a writing style after
years and that and and also I have to be
honest it may even be written by more
than one person as you guys pointed out
because some of the handwriting looks
completely different I'd love to
actually get like you know they do those
forensic handwriting people to like look
at this and be like oh yeah that's a 35
year old woman tomorrow we'll get that
somebody because somebody listen that's
the great thing about the internet and
if someone is looking at it right now
look like something like their W on like
the second to last line is more curved
than the one at the top like the
different sizes they're different
pressures on the paper yeah I mean white
wine why would they write precedent yeah
like they understand consistently they
know what Biden is but not president
like it's just it's like when they make
the r backwards to make it seem like a
kid wrote it oh here you take a look at
this in the word something the G is
written with starting from the middle
and going back and then down but then
the other G's are written in a very
different way this is written by
multiple people I think we should have
multiple children recreate this letter
just like
let's go to a drag show and have the
kids we'll pass around a piece of paper
there you go I can't do that I know
where we can find kids show
is like please help me my mom took me to
a drag show she's in there you go dollar
bills Robbie Starbucks says Charlotte
has another letter for you and she makes
a lot of sense in this one dear
President Biden I just wanted to tell
you something not fair to America
Ukraine is getting more money than
homeless veterans or broken roads our
border security and my parents combined
I think you should fix this and stop
giving tax dollars to them I'm a child
and even I know what you're doing is
stupid from Charlotte P.S please don't
pretend boys are girls anymore it sounds
crazy
Robbie and Landon his wife helped get a
bill passed against this kind of crazed
Trends stuff for kids in Tennessee so
kudos to Robbie and Landon on that they
did great work
that g is driving me nuts they're
different but it's just like it's the
most pretentious G ever
I'm sitting here in my notepad I'm I'm
I'm looking at how they made the G and
I'm like what what is this she is
taunting you yeah they wrote it one step
it was once again from a ransom note cut
out of the magazine
from calligraphy like they couldn't they
couldn't help but just like every letter
has to be busted up and weird looking
but the G they couldn't help but they're
like I have to put my Twirl in it do you
think that person has a g in their name
and they're used to it therefore writing
the G yeah
who did this
I don't know Joe Biden's a liar this is
so you think I don't know how she
spelled her name here's here's the thing
Biden supporters
look this letter purpose perfectly
exemplifies the difference between
Pro Biden and not pro Biden because
there are people who don't like Trump
but don't like Biden the the Democrat
people who think the economy is good
right now are the people who think this
is a real letter there there's an
overlap between the cognitive abilities
of the of the part the average person
who likes Biden and everyone else and
it's it's a deluded because they have
cognitive ability they're well educated
they're smart you know if you give an IQ
not the average person they would score
hot but a lot of the Biden support no no
the average the average ones no I
disagree all right then I'm looking more
at the ones who are running you know the
the woke agenda on the Midwest Midwest
slightly above average yeah they're not
they're not dumb and they're not fooled
right they're deluded they have deluded
themselves and like you said the ones
who grew up on Facebook's algorithm and
the rest of it and all their schools
everything they've been taught how do
you not believe that those are the
people you are told to trust you know so
everything they've been taught is wrong
yeah so how do you form an opinion
that's not going to be stupid and wrong
when you have nothing else to go on if
you are a functioning human being
and someone shows you
and someone says look at the sky what
color is it and you go it's blue no it's
red you go nah I'm pretty sure it's blue
and you're saying that for some weird
reason these are the kind of people that
go it's red
oh like when they said two plus two
equals five and then all of the Biden
people were like oh duplicate two equals
five now and they're like let me give
you some Consolidated reason why math is
wrong that was so frustrating to see to
see people just basically changing the
meanings of terms so that way they could
could semantically say that they were
right everyone changed I feel like yeah
just up in Chains we're in a simulation
and the purpose of the simulation is to
see if people of good nature and good
capability will stand up against
psychotic destruction there's a there's
an advanced civilization that created
this simulation we're all in and they're
like is it possible for humans to truly
pull through let's run a simulation and
see what happens nope no isn't that why
God wiped everything out twice right
aren't we failing that test we can
actually be building a a yacht of some
flavor maybe a giant boat we got a lot
of boats if the world flooded we got a
bunch of cruise liners which are
floating cities I think they'll be all
right but sometimes I just wonder about
the insanity that is you know what like
this letter from Joe Biden and the
things they do are so obviously fake
like there's no rational person is going
to believe it
and then we have people who really do
believe this stuff but think about it
now that the training starts in
preschool right they've got the kids
from preschool and nothing they're told
they get no reason reasoning
capabilities but I'm saying like it's
one thing if you believe things are not
true it's another thing if you can't
discern things in real time like outside
of politics if I went to someone and
said point to the pumpkin and they point
to a cucumber and I go actually that was
the you're correct that's or that's the
pumpkin like the fact that they can't be
like hey you're tricking me two plus two
isn't five they lack the capability to
even do that that's that's beyond
brainwashing like you can take a person
who grew up in a cult and then show them
truth and then they go oh my god what
have I done with my life I am being
woken up to the harsh realities of the
cult that I was in but these people
they're completely demoralized to the
point where you can be like
two plus students I go five here is two
and two and there's four and they go
nope and you're like okay
deprogramming people out of a cult
essentially you're identifying the
challenge we face
because the large majority of people in
this country for the past two
generations have been programmed to
believe things that are fundamentally
not true
and so they lack reasoning capability
and all the facts they've been trained
with their AI is all based on garbage
so how do we do that and it's a two
generation plus fight and that's that's
got to be back to the schools you know
you've got to have kids out of the
schools or you gotta have something else
but you have to be counter programming
because we're not going to deprogram we
can give up gen Z and the Millennials
are toast right those are they're sorry
but they're wasted Generations
are outliers no I think I'm the last
year of millennial how old are you I'm
27. so ask women their age too whatever
see all right here's the thing I am the
lead dog of Gen X if my birthday is when
Gen X started trust me on this I lived
the life everything I did was Gen X we
invented all the crazy Sports all that
stuff I lived it it's the last
generation where we actually lived the
American dream where things are better
than our parents where we were taught
reality all of those things that hasn't
happened for Millennials or for Gen Z
hear me out okay what if we took all the
Millennials put them on a bunch of big
boats and then brought them to their own
Island and said this is your country now
it'll be perfect because you've been
trained how to how to live a perfect
life right they've got the the right
programming for it what we should do is
we're making uh plans for Australia I
got an idea for a foreign
let's do this let's start a fundraiser
for a communist Utopia we'll buy an
island and then we'll tell all of the
communities United States you will get
to live in your communist Utopia we've
all pitched in our money together to
make it let's leave this horrible racist
Place load up all the commies on a boat
bring them to the island and say good
luck right I'm down speaking of
Communists today is the anniversary of
the death of Karl Marx is it a holiday
it should be I said that 3 14.
Pi Day is the day is the anniversary of
the death of Karl Marx wow yeah the
reason they wouldn't get on the boats is
because they already live in a communist
Paradise why would they go anywhere well
that's no they want to put us on tell
them they're going on the TV show love
Island they will go
through the interesting thing is they
don't want a communist Utopia they just
want to steal your stuff yeah because
they could set up a commune wherever
they wanted but they just want your
stuff Communists are motivated by hate
for the successful not by actual care
for other people correct they lie but
true communism has never been tried
that's because it's Global and it'll
never happen because all right we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com by clicking that
join us button if you like the work we
do and you want to keep happening become
a member at timcast.com and I believe
the Discord is done uh it is totally
done and can people get access to it now
or what
I have to speak to Andrew about that but
I'm pretty sure it's finished uh I'll
talk to him after the show three tiers
the lounge everyone gets access to
if you give 25 bucks or more you get
access to the VIP Suite where you get
voice chat it's a special voice chat
room or if you've been a member for at
least six months at 10 bucks a month you
get access as well we because we we did
this because we want to prevent Creeps
and Weirdos and you know far left
psychos from just coming in and screwing
with the voice chat but we didn't want
to make it only like so so the idea is
like okay what if you charge more so
that way it's harder for him to do it's
like yeah but that's not fair to regular
people well then what if you time gate
it's like well then antifa will just
come do both we do both and then we're
going to do a special club which is a
hundred bucks a month for the like elite
VIP room where our staff actually will
hanging out so if you're in the elite
club then you're actually hanging out in
the room with members of our staff and
things like that and uh people like Phil
who will be hanging out and talking
about stuff play guitar play guitar the
idea for the elite club is um
look obviously we want to make money
because we want to be able to invest in
the business time where people and do
more cool things but it's also just it
is about gatekeeping to a certain degree
like we want to create a cool cultural
space we don't want to lock people out
who can't afford it we do want to make
money so we're trying to find that
middle ground and do cool things so I I
think we're ultimately going to do with
the 100 a month package is have like at
the at the physical location you'll have
on you know unrestricted access to like
the the upstairs private club room and
something like that because we want to
create culture and and get people really
active and doing all this stuff but
we'll figure it out as we go
um I believe it's done it should be up
soon also you'll notice at timcast.com
the newsletter is now available people
have been clamoring for the newsletter
it is now available so sign up for that
and then what we're doing is I believe
once a week we give you like the
highlights of Articles episodes and
things you may have missed and uh this
way we get a direct line to you in the
event that we get censored shut down
band or otherwise we can send you guys
an email but you have to opt in because
we don't want to spam anybody so if you
choose to then you so then you'll get it
all right let's read some Super Chat
smash that like button
all right I'm not your buddy guy says
when I am weak I appeal to your values
when I'm strong I enforce mine there is
no good ending to this story
oh yeah Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
your 4 pm really spoke to how many how
many of us feel we want hard action
we're sick and tired of they them
pedoing the children and getting away
with it I don't care if it hurts
anyone's feelings disgust that's what
I'm saying man look I get it I like that
DeSantis revoked their their liquor
license I said I was really happy to
read that headline someone's doing
something but how did we go from a
society that would never allow it to now
being like well we allow most of it but
this one time we took away a liquor
license
we got to have the police go in and
arrest people who break the law that's
it and if they didn't break the law pass
a law that says you can't do it it's
Florida come on
all right Pupa chalupa good name says
DeSantis doesn't nearly go far enough
what does the left do they ban a girl's
basketball team for forfeiting against a
team with a man on it you guys hear that
yeah so what do you know the gist of it
like they're they're competing at like
States or some high level and they said
we won't compete against this other
school that has a male male ident or
male female identifying player and the
team that wouldn't play got in trouble
which seems crazy but
good for them though for them punished
for being bigoted question mark
all right Max Reddick says Tim I know
that uh you have known David Pacman for
a long time would you consider having
him on IRL to press him on some of these
issues uh I think we've invited David a
lot I just think he's he hosts his own
show so it's hard for him to do that
like
you know people gotta understand I got I
got nothing against David or Hassan or
jenk yuger when they're like not coming
on the show because they host their own
shows as for some other personalities
who said I will go on your show and then
privately we're like psych I'm not doing
it and then drag me on the internet for
internet for clicks and stuff yeah those
people are evil scumbags but as for the
other people who are like sorry man look
I host my own show Monday through Friday
I don't really have time to do this I go
you know what you're you're right
because neither do I I'm not going to
hold it against you uh that being said
I'd love to have David Pacman on I
believe we're actually trying to get
Kyle Kolinski and I need to message him
again because he's I think Kyle's
fantastic and and honest and he's
expressed interest in coming on before
I've talked to him a bit so that would
be really cool be cool to actually have
him and Crystal because I think they're
both great and um
and I think they are more likely to
understand what we're talking about but
I think Destiny's coming on soon and
um I think TJ Kirk as well
yeah so we're trying to fit everybody in
we're very very jammed you know with the
schedule I think the Amazing Atheist
we're we're trying to get on uh like
beginning of April or something and uh I
think he's gonna be a funny guy I think
he'll be he'll be a good show he's
rambunctious and he insults me on
Twitter but I think it'll be interesting
in in the conversation isn't that his
thing though he insults everybody on
Twitter yeah you've ever seen anybody
nice to anyone but it's it's like he
he's not
it's
it's sillier than that you know what I
mean like it's a it's an edgy kind of
you know it's not an angry vile like
attack yeah is he more of a sassy edgy
boy kind of thing he was just on with
sich and Adam and uh they they do a
podcast and he was like totally nice
during the the time that he was on and
then after he got off he was like
dogging him out he wasn't being super
mean or anything but he was like poking
at him I think Destiny is great you know
the Omni liberal I think is whatever uh
we've had him before uh I disagree with
him on some things but he's he's a good
dude he'll come in here I'll talk to you
and he'll make an argument and he knows
what he's talking about he's not full of
it so that that'll be fun too
all right am213 says
yeah only night I get to watch live that
prageru video was awesome share it uh I
finally did a prageru video I think I
actually have two and like one just came
out we did we I think we worked on two
of them but if you did like it or if you
didn't see it you should check it out
and um it's about lying liars and it's
like how many I asked how many times
does someone have to lie to you before
you will call them a liar and it's about
the corporate press and things like that
so you should definitely share that if
you really do like this I think it's a
message people need to hear as I rag on
the media incessantly
all right where are we at
what is this Olivia Claire says Etsy
finally paid me so hopefully other
creators are getting paid made lots of
sales today too but I'm still worried
about the next few months
yeah how's it been Olivia for for uh
business because like I've been saying
our ad rates have gone down and so
that's why I'm really pushing like
memberships because ad rates are
volatile and if uh in 2020 we were
solely an ad based show like it was just
YouTube ads and we did really really
well and then I thought to myself like
hey this is a really stupid idea because
if sponsors get pulled we're out of
business so we launched the website
shift a heavy focus into Sunday to
become a member because if you guys pay
10 bucks a month if one person pays 10
bucks a month that one that you know
once a month
we could lose all of our ads based on
how many members we have and still
operate the company and so with the
activists trying to get ads pulled and
constantly threatening people and with
the ad Market taking serious hits then
we need members the more members we have
the less worried we are about censorship
the less worried we are about add you
know the ad rates collapsing that being
said when we see ad rates go down
usually means y'all are hurting too so
you know do what you can
I just put it simply this way if there's
anything you could do if you don't feel
like doing anything else if you don't
want to speak up at work because you're
worried about losing your job
become a member by timcast.com it's 10
bucks a month and at the very least
you're helping us do shows like this and
more people are learning about this
stuff but do you you know I can be a
harder sales person but uh I want to be
I want to be real with you guys so let's
read some more Super chats Patriot
American says Tim I knew there's a
Subway beneath the capital it's for
emergency evacuations they touched upon
it in xXx State of the Union starring
Ice Cube ah classic Classics also for
people like Jerry Nadler who can't walk
the hundred yards between buildings he
looks like a hundred pounds of cow
manure put into a 50 pound bag he looks
awful are you talking about ad rates for
just a quick second one of the few
bipartisan issues right now in Congress
is actually attacking Facebook and
Google's domination of online ads and I
would actually want to I hope they do
something you know wouldn't that be nice
if they stopped the Monopoly that's
squashing creative activities online
yeah but the issue with the ad business
it's it's it's
because they're easier to use because
Google and Facebook own so much it's not
so much that they're shutting down the
competition it's just no they're doing
they're going to need Anti-Trust they're
not doing it based on content so it's
not got anything to do with the section
230 the rest of it they're actually
talking about they have a monopoly on it
but but you can't do anything about it
you can well can you Anti-Trust line
there are Anti-Trust torts what will
that do they can break up their force
them to sell off part of their ad
business force them to there's ways they
can say you have too much of this market
and actually that's existing legislative
they sell their ad business what does
the ad business become well they'd have
to break it up sell it to multiple
companies right and then you've got a
situation where they start competing
against each other because right now you
know you've got Facebook and Google
controls somewhere 75 to 80 that will
lower the ad rates if they're competing
against each other for Content not the
other way around so yeah you need
eyeballs to serve ads on Google and
Facebook now have all the eyeballs and
then what will happen is you're gonna
get a combination of two things
at the the various ad companies I I do
think it would probably be a net
positive if advertising was ripped from
Google as a company and became an
independent company or or several and a
bunch of ad agencies had to compete and
then what you would likely would end up
happening is let's say Google's Google
ads becomes company a b and c company a
will go to a channel like mine and say
we want an exclusivity deal with you
we'll give you X percent for x amount of
time and then that will likely give me a
better rate the problem is though
they'll say we're going to give you 75
of all the ad Revenue because YouTube
only does 65. for bigger channels I
think it is 75 but then Company B will
be like hold on there buddy we'll give
you 85 and then companies he says we'll
do 95. and then here's the worst part
those ad agencies then compete against
each other for the companies and so when
Coca-Cola comes to the ad agencies and
says who can get me the cheapest deal
per views they go I'll give you a
million views for a dollar and then they
go you got it and then up to go we got
you the deal here's your 95 cents I I
don't think anything you're saying is
wrong however when there is competition
right now there's none and so you've
just got Facebook and Google making the
decisions for everybody at least you've
got the option of negotiating with
somebody other than them cornering the
market and driving the price down
because they make those deals there's
two negotiating phases the
content producer and the Ad Agency and
then the Ad Agency and the and the ad
buyers and the problem is what works for
us right now is that YouTube basically
has an auction system where anybody who
comes in can place a bid and how much
they want to spend for an ad to appear
on this on this content so obviously
Coca-Cola can spend more than a smaller
Cola Company like RC Cola ain't spent in
those Coca-Cola dollars that means a
Coke ad is more likely to appear that
means I get a lot more money because
Coke knows all of these other channels
will this guy's gonna spend a dollar
he'll spend two he'll spend three I have
to spend four otherwise I don't get the
ad then I get four dollars you break it
all up the inverse happens Coca-Cola
goes to the Ad Agency and says what's
your rate four bucks no way I'm gonna
give a billion dollars to this company
because they're getting me in at a
dollar and then my ad rates drop by 90
so there's an advantage right now to
everything being done through a
centralized auction Market I I can
understand that I
it also the people who are pushing for
that are representing content producers
so it's not like their their goal is to
make the ad rates drop
all right let's read some more we got
Ken Authority says Dear Tim I'm sick of
War my last friend from enlisting post
911 died yesterday we were all so eager
for Revenge I hate War I hate violence I
hate that we got so very good at it and
stopped caring about the human cost I am
one such big said
sorry to hear it man I also believe war
is very very bad very bad Josh says Tim
Tim and Cassandra check out mostly
peaceful Latinas two super based women
who are doing real conservative work in
Florida would love to see them on IRL
I'll uh write that down what is that one
uh mostly
peaceful Latinas
there we go I'll take a look
all right what do we got here
corec 57 says Tim some of these people
are already registered sex offenders
Fair Point
Jackhammer says that liquor license can
easily be worth 250 000 in Miami so this
wasn't a slap on the wrist I understand
that and it's a Hyatt it's a very large
business
but their principal business is going to
be staying in a hotel room now don't get
me wrong there may be some guy who's
like let's get a hotel in Miami what do
you mean there's no liquor license get a
different Hotel honey I don't want to go
to a place that has no bar the reality
is I don't think most people who are are
thinking about that I used to travel for
work all the time and we'd go to the bar
sometimes and if the bar was like sorry
we're close we'd go okay and we'd go
somewhere else like we didn't think
twice we don't care you know so and to
be honest if you're on vacation you're
not going on vacation to go to the
heights bar you're going on vacation to
go to the fancy little Miami Beach Club
where they've got fancy little Miami
Beach drinks ninety percent of the bar
business for those people is is Joe
businessman during the week
you know yeah yeah and a lot of people
who stay will go downstairs and sit at
the bar with their buddies on a business
trip so it's bad for them they'll lose
money but I think the average person
who's traveling for work will sit at the
bar and have a soda and some wings with
their friend and be like can I get a bin
but don't have any but okay I guess
people aren't going to know their liquor
license got pulled they're still gonna
keep buying the rooms all the only
difference is when they go downstairs
they tell their buddy let's go
downstairs and grab lunch real quick at
the you know at the restaurant they'll
sit down and say I'll get the burger
french fries make a two potato fries
give me some of that that cheese dipping
sauce and I'll get a you know get a
Corona what do you mean you don't have
Corona all right give me a Diet Coke
that's what will happen that's that's
the only thing that's happened that's
what Ryan Sanders did
so so you know okay I guess
all right let's grab some more
all right
delimar says it is 100 the moms bringing
their literal pre-tweens to these events
they are on Facebook bragging about it
getting Zero pushback from other moms
I heard someone say something I don't
remember where it was it was on some
podcast and it was or maybe it was a
meme or something but it was something
like why do you think every religion
ever has severely restricted the
autonomy of women
I died laughing yeah but the issue
question where are their husbands and
dads in this scenario well if you look
at married women yeah they don't have
any of these issues
it is only and it and uh I think there's
a correlation between uh Millennial and
gen Z liberal men and women they have
really really high rates of mental
illness
so I think that's the issue
unfortunately because if you look at
conservative unmarried Millennial and
gen Z women they don't have these issues
either but maybe it's they are the Joker
ideology that attracts the broken and
dejected and that's why you get it
and it's the reinforcement you know you
you don't get shamed for doing that you
get reinforced and your virtue signaling
gets you points
all right valdren Olas says hey Tim and
crew my wife of 14 years died three
weeks ago tomorrow at the age of 34 and
your content has been instrumental in
helping me get through these rough times
thank you and never give up very sorry
to hear it man sincerest apologies I I
hope everything's going well in spite of
this you know and you're doing what you
can and uh thank you for listening to
the show and I'm glad we can be
something that that helps you yeah we
we're just a group of people who
complain on the internet about our
feelings condolences yeah condolences
all right what do we got
here we go
the downstream says Hey guys big fan
might be late to the party or not
related to today's topics but Tim or Ian
might find it coincidental like I did
that Barney Frank aka the roll the dice
guy is a sitting board member at
Signature Bank odd very interesting he
was making a lot of comments about uh
the solvency or he was saying that the
the bank actually wasn't insolvent and
that was lending I guess uh support to
the argument that this was an
intentional move by the government to
push back crypto hey I got a I got an
easy one here hunter killer 86 says Tim
are we going to also ban Gwar or
Ramstein shows because they show sex
acts too
no we don't let children go to them
because this is the weirdest thing this
is why I think like a comment like this
comes from someone who doesn't actually
watch the show they watch to The Young
Turks then came here commented and then
left because like the first thing I said
was and I said all the time I don't care
about drag shows if you want to have a
drag show I'll show up and I'll smile
and laugh and high five with all my
friends and beg what a funny show no
kids though that simple that's why I say
like I'll I'll you know it's expensive
to do and I was like I'll do it you want
me to do it I'll put on a big drag show
we'll have free food and drinks 21 and
up obviously and then you can have your
drag show and then strangely
none of them took me up on the offer I
wonder why it is that not one of these
people wanted to have a drag show that
was only for adults his dress his shows
suck without kids apparently for these
people as soon as I said no kids they
were like wow
I mean that's the way it's only fun if
you bring miners it's not I mean first
of all no one wants to watch them dance
when they were at least singing Abba
Tunes you know we got Dancing Queen all
right which I dig that's one of my
favorite songs it is a great song but
now what do you get you get gyrating men
dressed in women stripper shows it's
King shows like
DeSantis is attacking lgbtq people like
I feel like most of those letters are
like leave us out of it we do not want
miners at our you know 21 and up bar it
seems weird that this is the the issue
they're lumping everyone on I started
talking about normal gay people
right the normal gays are sick of the
freaks yeah yeah you know and well
that's why you have gays against a
groomers right because the actual well
so so the LGBT community
has been fighting for a very very long
time just to live their lives and then
Along Came the Q portion the Q Plus and
now you have a very very strange
plethora of ideologies that don't
connect in any way so the interesting
thing is
a lot of the activists that I know said
they're they're they're not sure how LGB
and T Go together but they're willing to
be a part of this fight because there is
some overlap in in how someone perceived
a sexuality versus identity but then
when it got to the Q Plus now you have
like non-binary two-spirit they them
nightmare two spirit makes it purely
obvious that it's a religion right like
that is undeniable like many of these
people were circular HBS but now they
believe in spirits or or they or they're
like we respect people who believe in
spirits I don't and I I'm sorry so so
the issue is yeah there's gaze against
rumors and they're being called
homophobic and transphobic when they're
literally gay and trans and bi and
lesbian and all that stuff it goes back
to the are you Live and Let Live or are
you forcing people to celebrate your
freakishness and right now the freaks
are winning
yep
all right let's read some more what do
we got here Raymond g Stanley Jr says if
no U.S intervention I got 20 on Russia
I'm not taking that bet
you don't think Russia would win if the
U.S no I think that them with it oh
right right right no exactly yeah as
soon as the U.S removes which is means
anyone who's saying zelinski won't come
to the table is full of it and Putin
will come to the table even though they
both will say they won't until somebody
makes them and we both have we have the
ability to do that we just won't normies
get out says Terry Crews is on some sort
of PR campaign doing appearances as
president Camacho I wonder if they're
planning a sequel
we had talked with Mike Judge a while
back
um about coming on the show and talking
about all the stuff with like you know
idiocracy in mind and um I should reach
out to him because we're doing Friday
mornings we're doing the culture War
podcast which is more conversational
less news driven and uh I think that'd
be great to have him on that we just
talk about all this stuff it'd be good
fun yeah a lot of people we had uh
Damien Eccles of The West Memphis Three
last Friday a lot a lot of people who
would love to sit down to have a
conversation don't want to come on a
political cultural commentary show
because like you want me to talk about
what it's like well there was a bank
collapse like bro I write comic books
it's like okay well you know you don't
have a hot take on that man what's wrong
with you
so mostly we have political commentators
politicians and activists who come on
this this show
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
hi it's Raymond I'm a regular here my
dude for my birthday can you please say
where is she where is she it's your
birthday dude happy birthday yeah there
you go you know you know the line right
from AOC
AOC said that she had a knock on our
door and she went hit in the bathroom
and then she heard someone where is she
yeah but like blocks away that's two
buildings away an hour before the
building was breached she was psychic
and she saw a vision of the future her
eyes turned white and she saw them an
hour later storming the capital then
when she heard the knocks she goes it
must have happened sooner than my
premonition
or she's made the whole thing up because
she lies how about she got a note from
Charlotte telling her about it yeah
Charlotte warned her dear AOC
the insurrectionists are coming hide
love Charlotte classic Charlotte yeah
her crazy geez what is this girl doing
all right where are we at let's get some
more Super chants
Joel X line says
I'm 30 minutes behind and I just heard
the guest say the U.S didn't blow up the
Nord stream LOL I'm guessing he didn't
read sei's substack we 100 did
no they equip ukrainians and then go Oh
look The ukrainians are doing that thing
that we wanted them to do with our
equipment and tools
I'm still out I'll be honest I'm still
not convinced it was
at a Biden level of approval
I think the ukrainians did what is our
money well what is fair point but I
think the ukrainians did it with our
money because they were afraid people
gonna lose their focus on his war and he
needed something to scare Europe and
everybody else about the energy so I
think it was more zelenski I think if he
was smart he did it and then everybody
said oops I heard that that pipeline is
encased in like like it's surrounded by
like three inches of concrete I don't
know I'm just repeating stuff that I it
was a legitimate but that's a detonation
that's a serious pipeline to be blowing
up and if it's here we go surrounded by
concrete Miguel Rivera says Tim most
schools don't teach cursive anymore
anyways yep that's what you were saying
right yeah so how is there that cursive
G in there because wine moms when they
were younger were Todd cursing yep
because maybe what actually happened is
a 40 year old woman I like I won't be
surprised if a 40 year old woman wrote
the letter and sent it in and said now
everyone's gonna think because this is
what these these crackpot Psychopaths do
look man
um I'm at my Woodside with this stuff I
was watching I was watching that
interview
clip of it from the um
the ocean dyro brothers or is that their
names were the uh
that's so good and this is the left they
just lie about everything they're like
my son came in today and said Daddy why
are why aren't we supporting Ukraine
Russia is basically like World War II
Germany and if we don't stop it now
Biden will be this generation's Neville
Chamberlain and then I said to my son
that's a deep question son we high five
and everyone clapped that's what they do
all the time they post these ridiculous
garbled pieces of garbage that never
happened but they are all stupid enough
and believe each other or at least
pretend to they're a lot I'm sick of it
there's a lot of people on the left
specifically the people that are like
the thought leaders that believe that
the truth is Downstream from power they
believe that if you articulate things
and you believe it enough that that's
enough to make it reality which is part
of why the left is where the trans
ideology lives because they believe if
you say it that the truth is Downstream
from power so if you say it and act it
out then it becomes true
is insane well add projection in which
if you look at all the fake hate crimes
you know they're like oh wait a minute
I'm scared of black people someone would
probably put a noose in here because
they hate black people so you add all
those in projection and the ability to
make reality out of the fantasies in
your own mind and ta-da right that's
woke ideology it's uh them Street I am
pandysis says Hyatts do a lot of
weddings they lose almost all of their
function hall Revenue fair point that I
that I do agree with so not going to a
dry wedding that's right yeah no
nobody's gonna do that but I still think
it's like a person a tiny a single digit
percentage if at most because that's
like a fraction or percentage before
single digit percentage then so they're
probably going like Ugh I roll call the
lawyers the Hyatt Corporation that's
worth tens of billions or more hundreds
of billions is probably being like get
the corporate lawyers make a phone call
we'll get this reversed in a week when
the news dies down and then no no bad
and I think I'm gonna get you a SWAT
rate in Florida dude it is my goal well
we don't need SWAT we need one
overweight state trooper to walk up real
slow and go
hey you're the manager of this
establishment
just turn around give me your head
around your butt do not give them drag
that's it that's it and then the manager
gets arrested he goes hey we're not a
sexual for kids you're under arrest and
you write your main sound and that's it
all right one one portly fella with who
because Hey Nobody's running nobody's
fighting this you don't need a SWAT team
I just I had the idea I wanted tear gas
and drag queens man for some reason that
to me was gonna be just a joke only I
mean if you're talking about people who
are violent but if we're talking about
making an arrest we just need one cop to
walk up and just and you you don't even
need cuffs jackets we're going to the
station we just have drag queens like
vow not to perform in front of children
like I don't understand why they're not
because the drag queens don't want to do
that I know that's not even fair because
there's a lot of drag queens who have
been complaining about it there was a
viral video on Twitter of a drag queen
being like why are people bringing kids
to this stuff we're trying to do an
adult show here but then the creepy
Pinos are pretending that they're it's
all just they're they're using the LGBT
community as a mask for their grooming
or their freaking the issue is the media
is protecting them all right let's uh
let's well you know we're gonna do we're
gonna go to the members only show so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com click join us
in about 10 minutes we will have on the
front page the uncensored after show you
click it you can watch the after show
live it will of course be archived after
we're done streaming it and you can
watch it whenever you want so again
that'll be up in about 10 minutes you
can follow the show at timcastirl you
can follow me personally at timcast Jim
do you want to shout anything up at Jim
Hanson DC and my awesome how to book get
based and you will end up leaning back
on a Jaguar I'm looking cool like I was
oh there you go
I am uh Phil Labonte lead singer of All
That Remains on Phil that remains on
Twitter I am Philip remains official on
Instagram give me a follow and we can
poop on the commies
uh hey I'm Hannah brimo you should
follow at timcast news on Instagram and
Twitter it's where you can see work from
me and all of our other journalists you
can follow me personally on Twitter at
HC brimelow and you can follow me on
Instagram at hannahclar.b there are some
fake accounts floating around I'm not
Hannah claire.bb I'm not Hannah
claire.b1 those are fake don't follow
them they'll send you weird advice about
crypto I don't give out advice about
crypto okay thanks have a good night
uh and uh that sucks I know how to just
be impersonated I am at surge.com
um
yeah that was fun thanks for coming Jim
it's been a pleasure chatting appreciate
it man at search.com that's way too
simple yeah people struggle with finding
it I think that's cool yeah
s-e-r-g-e-d-o-t-c-o-m it's pretty simple
guys all right everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.com in about five or
ten minutes thanks for hanging out